[Musique]
une gabriela tall secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse est l'invité
d'auditions publiques bonsoir et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à l'invitation des chaînes
parlementaires public sénat lcp
assemblée nationale à l'invitation
également de la fp et du figaro
d'ailleurs le
les internautes qui suivent des missions
sur le site du figaro peuvent réagir
intervenir poser leurs questions à laizy
je me ferais votre interprète vous
intervenez sur le chat du figaro bien
sûr gabriela talent vous allez répondre
au cours de cette émission
comme chaque semaine c'est la règle à
deux parlementaires et donc vous serez
tout à l'heure interpellé par ladislas
poniatowski sénateur et l'air de l'heure
et george pau langevin députée
socialiste de paris les journalistes et
ils sont déjà 2 à être présent avec nous
françois-xavier bourmaud et jérémy marc
aumont soir messieurs tout à l'heure au
rayonnement de chimie à brigitte boucher
nous rejoindront nous en parler bien sûr
du grand débat et de son issue en france
mais d'abord évidemment gabriela talent
la formation qui nous est parvenu il ya
quelques minutes donc en algérie le
président bouteflika renonce à briguer
un cinquième mandat après évidemment la
force de la rue on a vu ces
manifestations monstres et pacifique en
algérie
quelle est votre réaction à l'instant
sur cette décision qui nous arrive donc
d'algérie côté la france prend acte du
renoncement du président bouteflika
je crois pas avoir beaucoup d'autre
commentaire à faire vous savez depuis le
début de cette mobilisation
j'ai beaucoup été interrogé sur ce sujet
là il se trouve que moi je discute
beaucoup compris avec des algériens et
ils tiennent eux est-ce qu'on respecte
leur indépendance leur souveraineté on
vienne pas faire de l'ingérence dans un
sens ou dans l'autre dans cette
situation qui relève avant tout du
peuple algerien ouvert respectons tous
mais nous avons tous été marqués
peut-être comme vous par ces
manifestations est ce que c'était
effectivement la solution qui devait
finir par s'imposer à l'évidence c'est
une prise en compte de la mobilisation
très forte qui a eu lieu en algérie
encore une fois maintenant c'est au
peuple algérien souverain d'organiser
la succession la prochaine élection
présidentielle dont je comprends qu'elle
ait retardé pour des raisons
d'organisation et évidemment la france
suivra avec attention comme elle le fait
depuis le début de cette situation ce
qui se passe en algérie avec l'espoir
peut-être que l'algérie se dote d'une
cantiste d'une constitution qui lui
garantissent bien le fonctionnement
d'une démocratie pleine et entière c'est
encore une fois au peuple algérien que
je n'aurais pas plus menacé quand même
dit non au fond de vous même vous avez
été quand même marqué comme nous tous
j'imagine par l'ampleur et la nature des
manifestations qui ont fait vaciller le
régime
évidemment qu'il est on a tous vu une
mobilisation d'ampleur ne serait-ce
qu'en france d'ailleurs où il ya
beaucoup de binationaux
l'algérien qui ont manifesté aussi il y
avait dix mille personnes à paris hier
et donc c'est une prise en compte de
cette mobilisation
alors on va parler d'un coq de la france
avec la sortie du grand débat comment
éviter que ce soit la déception pour les
français ce qui est certain c'est que il
ya beaucoup d'attentes sur la sortie de
ce grand débat et que c'est une attente
qui à la mesure de l'intérêt qui a eu
pour le grand débat si on s'était vus il
ya quelques semaines ou quelques mois
on m'aurait posé des questions avec des
doutes de savoir si finalement ce débat
allait servir à quelque chose si les
français elle à y participer
on serait pas du tout posé la question
du risque de déception il faut se
replonger un peu en arrière pour pour le
mesurer il ya eu un succès et il ya
toujours un succès avec ce grand débat
quand je rappelle qu'il n'est pas
terminée
les français peuvent continuer à faire
des réunions à faire des contributions
et donc il faudrait à rebours est
déclenché il faudra être à la hauteur
dans la réponse politique mais je n'ai
absolument pas de doute sur le sujet
puisque la première phase s'achève
vendredi l'on va rentrer dans la phase
des conférences citoyennes et des des
conférences thématiques mais pour
l'instant le grand débat vous le disiez
tu es un succès de participation on voit
pourtant toujours pas ce qui peut en
sortir là vous étiez une réunion à
matignon sur le sujet hier qu'est ce qui
s'y est dit c'était on est un
plusieurs ministres avoir été réunies
effectivement autour du premier ministre
c'était avant tout une réunion de
méthode pour
voir comment les choses se déroulaient
dans les nouvelles étapes puisque vous
l'avez dit elle et conférence nationale
thématique d'ailleurs je viens à
l'instant de quitter une conférence
nationale thématique sur démocratie et
citoyenneté qui réunissent c'est très
intéressant comme exercice et tous ceux
qui étaient présents ont dit que c'était
inédit aussi qui réunissent l'ensemble
des corps intermédiaires partenaires
sociaux associations d'élus reste qu'on
présente en des associations pour
réfléchir ensemble et faire des
propositions sur les quatre grandes
thématiques du débat ce qu'on a constaté
aussi hier autour du premier ministre
c'est qu'il ya des sujets qui ont émergé
qui n'était pas nécessairement des
sujets immédiatement fléché dans les
quatre thématiques et qu'il faudra les
prendre en compte par exemple la
question de l'emploi et du développement
économique en tant que tel qui n'était
pas une thématique en tant que tel la
question de l'éducation aussi évidemment
ça m'intéresse beaucoup puisque j'ai
auprès de jean michel blanquer air au
gouvernement et contre nos portes ces
sujets là ça fait partie des thématiques
qui ont émergé c'est ce qu'on a constaté
maintenant il faut coder nouvelle les
prochaines étapes et lieu c'est très
important il ya des conférences
citoyennes qui commenceront à ce
week-end là aussi c'est inédit pour la
première fois on fait ce qui existe
aujourd'hui dans les jurys d'assises par
exemple pour la justice on le fait au
niveau de la décision politique et c'est
franchement inédit d'avoir dans chaque
région une assemblée de citoyens tirés
au sort qui vont faire des propositions
justement jusqu'au moment où l'exécutif
fera ses propositions
donc si on a bien compris cela devrait
être autour de la mi avril
comment éviter que les faire retomber un
peu comme un soufflet qui ne se passe
rien comment vous allez animer ce moment
c'est très séquencé vous avez donc cette
semaine et conférence nationale
thématique ce week-end et le week-end
prochain
des conférences régionales citoyenne et
une conférence qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur
qui de conférences qui va réunir le 22
mars à aix en provence des jeunes tirés
au sort dans toute la france j'irai les
accueillir c'est important de ne pas
perturber les échanges mais des jeunes
tirés au sort dans toute la france parce
que il faut un cadre spécifique pour
permettre aux jeunes de s'exprimer cela
surtout du coeur de bien vous voulez
vous parlait toujours de cette
délibération permanence et qui
aujourd'hui je vous donnais des éléments
de fond sur la sortie vous seriez tout à
fait fondés à veut dire
attendez à quoi sert le débat qui
désavouent déjà aujourd'hui vous
connaissez l'atterrissage et les points
de sortie on respecte chacune des étapes
et après les conférences citoyennes que
je viens d'évoquer
il y aura le temps parlementaire ou là
les députés en tant que représentant de
la nation
s'emparant des différents sujets ça nous
amène pas très loin tout ça à la
mi-avril donc mi avril il y aura une
expression du président de la république
il tirera les enseignements que le grand
débat on a l'impression que le grand
débat ressemble à la grande marche qui
avait servi et même accro à construire
son programme présidentiel est ce que le
président de la république affaiblie par
la crise des gilets jaunes est en train
de reconstruire un programme pour la
deuxième partie de son mandat ou et puis
comment est ce qui compte le faire
valider par les français une fois que
les propositions seront une fois qu'il
les aura avancé ce qui est certain c'est
que un certain nombre de constats qu'on
fait aujourd'hui avec la crise des
gilets jaunes qui ont été portées par
des jeunes par des français qu'on entend
dans les grands débats cd constat qu'on
avait fait à l'occasion de la grande
marche pendant la campagne
présidentielle
évidemment sur la question de la
ruralité sur la question des services
publics sur la question des statuts sur
la question de la capacité à s'émanciper
par le travail c'est des choses que des
constats qu'on avait faits et de
évidemment ce qu'on a constaté c'est que
n'était pas allé suffisamment vite sur
un certain nombre de points est sans
doute que dans la pratique du pouvoir
on n'avait pas suffisamment associés
comme on est en train de le faire c'est
aussi aujourd'hui fausse route peut-être
aussi je vient peut-être de mea culpa
aussi je viens de vous le
dire notamment en termes de méthode est
sans doute qu'à la sortie du grand débat
il faudra proposer un cadre de débat et
de participation permanente pour la
suite simplement pour l'être pour la
suite des opérations
mais ce qui est certain méthode par
exemple on entend aujourd'hui des voix à
la république en marche d'hier il le
faut il ne faut plus désindexer par
exemple les retraites est donc là c'est
bien une critique de ce qui était mené
jusqu'à présent mais ça ça fait partie
des propositions qui ont été portées
activement par stanislas guéri mais vous
avez bien vu que dans les annonces du
président de la république en décembre
et notamment un point il est il à dizzy
qu'on revenait sur la hausse de csg qui
avait été annoncé et qui avait été mise
en place pour les notamment les
retraités
jusqu'à 2000 euros on est revenu sur
cette décision c'est bien que on a tenu
compte du fait que peut-être cette
décision était trop fort peut-être
qu'elle n'était pas suffisamment juste
qu'elle frapper trop durement des
retraités donc cette part de mea culpa
on l'a fait mais ce qui est certain et
je pense que personne ne nie ce fait
c'est que ce qui s'est passé le 17
novembre avec le mouvement des jeunes et
jaune c'est une cocotte minute qui
bouillait depuis des décennies le
couvert qui a sauté
voilà et aujourd'hui nous on prend nos
responsabilités et on fait en sorte
d'être à la hauteur de la réponse qui
est nécessaire pour la pomme rose à
l'émission pour l'instant je ne
comprends pas très bien où on va saper
le concours lépine delà de la
proposition c'est un jour une
proposition parmi nice par député ce qui
n'est pas de temps de mettre un peu de
l'ordre dans tout ça tu siffles et la
fin de la récré et dire bon voilà voilà
où est ce qu'on va aller dans un mois
sera au terme de ce grand débat alors je
peux comprendre c'est très long surtout
pour des personnes qui sont ses
partenaires d'élite ont nommé par les
jeunes a pas de proposition de sortie
pour l'instant et en même temps chacun
ce que je vous dis c'est qu'on n'annonce
pas de propositions de sorties alors
même que le débat se poursuit évidemment
il ya des propositions qui remonte on
est en train d'en faire l'analyse qui a
un travail de synthèse qui est massif
on a commencé avec les cahiers citoyens
on a aujourd'hui dix mille cahiers
citoyens qui ont été numérisés sur les
16000 qui ont été proposés dans les
mairies on travaille à partir du 18 mars
sur la synthétisation des propositions
qui sont remontés sur la plateforme on
est quasiment un million cinq cent mille
contributions qui ont été postées sur la
plateforme ces massifs
donc ce travail là il va être fait
évidemment nous on commence à réfléchir
il ya des propositions qui sont faites
par des formations politiques par des
associations par des partenaires sociaux
ministre par des ministres aussi alors
justement vous même vous en avez des
propos est ce que par exemple la réforme
de l'héritage que vous avez envie de
porter fait partie des réponses selon
vous et la crise des gilets jours c'est
un chantier que j'ai ouvert j'ai ouvert
avant le grand débat et qui vise à dire
que il faut permettre en france de
développer ce qu'on appelle une
philanthropie à la française on permet à
des personnes qui en ont les moyens et
qui en ont envie de s'engager davantage
pour les associations pour le
financement de la vie associative en
compte détriment de leurs descendants de
leurs enfants
bon on peut voir les choses comme ça en
tout cas pour la société et pour le
développement de la vie associative moi
je pense qu'il faut laisser le choix aux
français s'agit pas de contraintes
s'agit pas d'imposer il s'agit de dire
qu' il faut donner des libertés pour
soutenir des oeuvres à soutenir des
causes associatives soutenir des
fondations si on en a envie
ça fait partie des sujets sur lesquels
je travaille mais si on parle de la
question du grand débat et de la
question des associations pour le coup
il ya une proposition comporte avec jean
michel blanquer a dans le cadre de ce
grand débat c'est le fait d'avoir un
financement des associations au niveau
local sur les fonds de l'état qui se
fasse avec la participation citoyenne
il ya beaucoup de collectivités qui ont
développé ce qu'on appelle des budgets
participatifs qui permettent à des
citoyens de voter pour attribuer des
budgets le seul endroit on le fait pas
c'est l'état l'état reste une forteresse
sur ce point là et donc ce qu'on propose
avec jean michel blanquer
c'est de dire dans chaque département on
a des fonds développement de la vie
associative qui sont proposés et un
groupe de citoyens tirés au sort qui
décide de l'attribution des subventions
aux associations
c'est à la fois un enjeu de
développement la vie associative c'est
aussi un enjeu de participation
citoyenne et on voit bien que les
français veulent pouvoir participer
davantage aux décisions
jérémy alors autre proposition lancée
dans le débat hier par stanislas guérini
c'est cette idée de travailler un jour
de plus pour financer la dépendance en
fait vous nous refaites le coup de la
journée de solidarité qui avait été
inventé il ya 15 ans l'a refait tous les
15 ans pour financer cette dépendance
c'est ça l'idée enfin je pense qu'il
faut regarder toutes les propositions et
qu'il ya une réforme d'ampleur de la
dépendance qui va
arrivé sur laquelle agnès buzyn
travaille avec son équipe et que dans ce
cadre là ça peut évidemment faire partie
des pistes pour le financement de cette
réforme qui est extrêmement importante
la part des personnes âgées dans la
population française n'est rien
aujourd'hui par rapport à celle qu'elle
sera demain et après demain et donc il
faut l'anticiper
il faut permettre de se donner les
moyens d'accompagner dignement les
personnes dans leur autonomie en
lorsqu'elles sont âgés et dans toutes
ces propositions qu'on évoquait il ya la
grande majorité quand même tourné autour
de l'impôt et la fiscalité est ce que
vous pouvez aujourd'hui garantir aux
français qu' à l'issue du grand débat
les impôts n'augmenteront pas moi je
suis constant sur ce point et c'est vrai
qu'il ya des propositions qui ont été
faites et qui ont émergé proposé des
augmentations d'impôts ou équivalent et
moi je continue à dire que je ne
considère pas qu'on puisse sortir d'un
grand débat et d'une mobilisation qui a
été engagée sur contre une hausse de
taxes par des hausses d'impôts moi je
souhaite que les impôts n'augmentent pas
voir même qu'ils puissent baisser pour
un certain nombre de personnes qui
travaillent et qui aujourd'hui ont du
mal à boucler les fins de mois
je rappelle quand même qu'il ya une
première réponse on décembre dernier du
président de la république avec la
hausse de la prime d'activité avec la
prime exceptionnelle salariales dans les
entreprises avec la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires
est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin c'est
ce qu'on est en train de regarder avec
le grand débat potentiellement pourra
avoir une réponse ces niveaux-là suppose
des économies en contrepartie alors si
on va faire des baisses d'impôts l'heure
où lesquels sur quelle qu'elle soit
l'expérience ça fait partie des sujets
qu'on est en train de regarder dans la
lettre du président de la république qui
a initié le grand débat s'est dit
explicitement et clairement on peut
imaginer des baisses d'impôts
supplémentaires on peut imaginer des
services publics renforcer
supplémentaires mais il faut que y est
de l'autre côté le financement et donc
où est ce qu'on va chercher de
financement ou est ce qu'on peut faire
des économies
ça fait partie du dialogue qui a
aujourd'hui entre les français entre les
partenaires sociaux et les corps
intermédiaires et sur lequel on est là
dessus les des pistes qui apparaissent
aujourd'hui sur les économies à réaliser
écoutez déjà là aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de synthétisation qui est
en cours il ya des propositions qui
remonte aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
d'annoncé à faire sur le sujet d'hier
quand il ya des pistes qui sont avancés
ou des annonces qui sont faites par des
ministres on nous le reproche assez
régulièrement donc moi je fais attention
aussi à ça mais évidemment
l'objectif n'est pas de
de proposer des mesures qui ne seraient
pas financées ou qui viendrait on prend
l'équilibré budgétaire qui est important
de retrouver vous disent pas de hausses
d'impôts mais la république en marche
propose d'alourdir l'ifi il ya quand
même cette exigence de justice fiscale
avec l'idée de faire contribuer plus les
hauts revenus est ce que il n'est pas
temps d'envoyer un signe justement aux
gens en faisant faisant faisant ça moi
je considère que ont fait pas de
politique par les symboles et que
peut-être que c'est ce qui a trop été
fait ces dernières années
vous dites envoyer un signe vous dites
faire contribuer plus certains c'est pas
de ta paix entre guillemets assurent
certains qui fera plaisir à d'autres et
donc pour moi l'enjeu n'est pas de faire
du symbolique mais c'est de faire de
pratiques et de l'efficace nous notre
ligne fiscale est très simple est de
dire que on veut une fiscalité qui
servent l'investissement et l'économie
et c'est ce qu'on a mis en place depuis
deux ans avec un seul objectif de faire
en sorte que l''indice mort parce que la
croissance reparte que l'économie
reparte il ya jamais eu autant
d'investissements dans nos entreprises
depuis dix ans que l'an dernier
il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'investissements étrangers que l'an
dernier je fais beaucoup de déplacements
en province
je vois des investissements nouveaux qui
arrivent jetés dans les ardennes il ya
eu une série talent qui va ouvrir c'est
quasiment 1000 salariés c'est une
entreprise algérienne qui a décidé de
venir implanter une usine en france
l'industrie en france parce qu'il ya ce
nouveau cadre qui existe qui est
favorable à l'économie et donc moi je
suis plutôt pour qu'on reste sur cette
ligne est ce que vous redoutez léger
jaune samedi qui veulent marquer
distille un grand coup pour la fin du
grand débat où est ce que pour vous
c'est terminé c'est fini moi je
d'abord ce n'est pas la fin du grand
débat je le rappelle puisque la casa
sports suivent à contrer que ça se
prolongerait ensuite moi je pense pas
que les français aujourd'hui attendre
des grands coups je pense qu'ils
attendent que ça marche nous attendent
des solutions ils attendent qu'on aille
de l'avant et on le voit dans la
mobilisation
des gilets jaunes où chaque samedi c'est
vrai qu'il ya une mobilisation en baisse
peut-être qu'il reste un socle qui a
décidé de se mobiliser semaine après
semaine
vous l'avez identifiés ou comment est ce
que vous le décrire ce que je le définis
comme ayant finalement beaucoup moins de
propositions concrètes sur le quotidien
des français mais beaucoup plus de
positions de contestation du président
de la république de la légitimité de la
majorité est un souhait de renverser
finalement une majorité et ça on peut
évidemment pas s'accorder avec cette
ligne là il ya des élections on les
respecte et on agit pour répondre aux
attentes des français
on a vu pendant le tout la crise des
gilet jaune volonté de créer des listes
européennes qui ont des listes
européennes là aujourd'hui les jeunes de
plus en plus de mal à se lancer ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le pour la
majorité c'est franchement je ferai pas
trop de l'analyse politique de cette
situation là moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que si les personnes en
l'occurrence gilet jaune se mobilisent
parce qu'elles considèrent que dans
l'offre politique
il n'y a pas de réponse à leurs attentes
et à leurs mobilisations
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'elle puisse
proposer proposer une alternative
politique après c'est à eux de
s'organiser et de voir dans quelle
mesure ils sont capables de le faire ce
qui est certain c'est que ce qu'on voit
dans ce mouvement des gilets jaunes
c'est là aussi qu'il ya beaucoup
d'inventions paradoxal et de position
contradictoires entre ceux qui veulent
augmenter un certain nombre de dépenses
etc
d'autres qui disent qu'il ya trop de
d'impôts et autres taxes et qu' ils ceux
qui sont sur une ligne un peu différente
voilà il ya quand même des positions qui
sont assez assez différente donc je
comprends la difficulté à s'organiser
politiquement c'est la question jérémy
lorsque la question à 1000 euros la tête
de liste pour les européennes
vous êtes plutôt pour qu'il y ait besoin
d'un télé l'oiseau on comprend pas bien
où ça en est où peut-être une troisième
personne à laquelle on n'a pas pensé
profiter moi je
n'ai pas d'information vous citer deux
collègues ministres que j'apprécie
beaucoup et qu'il travaille très bien
qu'ils sont des femmes exceptionnelles
de qualité ces deux là également la lie
connaissance elles n'ont pas dit qu'elle
était candidate en tout cas pas
publiquement pour mener la liste
donc moi je sais que quand même
compliqué de me positionner pour des
personnes qui ne sont pas au clame
qu'elle n'est pas candidate elle le dit
sur sur tous les toits et en même temps
elle est soutenue on sent que jean la
pousse bien que ce soit elle vend de ses
compétences
qu'est ce qu'il faut en penser ce qui
est certain c'est que nathalie oiseaux
c'est une femme de très grande
compétence
c'est une femme qui fait aujourd'hui un
travail remarquable pour défendre les
intérêts de la france en europe au
moment du brésil it au moment de la
poussée nationaliste et elle a une vraie
expertise sur le sujet ça veut pas dire
que c'est une des signes déclarations de
soutenir une candidature qui n'a pas été
déclaré
mais en tout cas on peut que reconnaître
les qualités de nathalie loiseau le
premier ministre a dit récemment qu'il
fallait consolider la majorité au centre
droit est ce que c'est votre vie où il a
dit c'est votre vision aussi écouter
enfin moi j'ai pas vu cette déclaration
nous on a une position qui n'est pas
centriste mais centrale
effectivement on est un certain nombre
de personnes à avoir rejoint emmanuel
macron a aujourd'hui faire partie de la
majorité qui viennent de la gauche c'est
plutôt mon cas viennent de la droite
c'est plutôt le cas d'autres y compris
deux collègues ministres et on est
rassemblée autour d'un programme qu'on
applique autour d'une ligne politique et
autour de propositions et de chantier
qu'on va y compris ouvrir à l'issue de
ce grand débat vous avez reçu le soutien
d'alain juppé et de jean pierre raffarin
mais pourtant on voit que la liste les
républicains commence à frémir un peu
dans les sondages est ce que ça signe la
fin de la recomposition politique avec
l'idée que
ces prises de guerre chez les
républicains allait affaiblir la droite
moi je crois pas vous savez les
dynamiques politiques je les analyse
patent au sondage et au frémissement
d'un pour cent ou de 0,5 ou de 0,5 point
les analyses à la dynamique et c'est
vrai qu'on voit que autour de la
position et du cap porté par emmanuel
macron en europe et un rassemblement
très large qui d'ailleurs dépasse le
rassemblement qui avaient eu lieu autour
de sa candidature au moment des
élections présidentielles et de le fêter
qui a un temps de 1 100 nouveaux de
d'élargissement politique autour de
cette position européenne
on le voit aussi avec des écologistes
qui qui nous rejoignent pascal durand
récemment dans la presse a annoncé qu'il
rejoignait la république en marche pour
les élections européennes
parce qu'on porte un projet extrêmement
ambitieux notamment en terme
environnemental et écologique et donc il
ya cette dynamique qui est là on verra
bien au moment des élections et du vote
ce que ça donnera merci messieurs ce la
fin de la première partie mais tout de
suite la seconde
la deuxième partie précisément de
l'émission avec les deux parlementaires
qui font leur entrée sur le plateau
voilà nous rejoignent donc comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure ladislas
poniatowski bonsoir et george pau
langevin bonsoir à vous merci d'être là
une question d'un internaute du figaro
je vous l'avais annoncé alors la
question est quand même très ouverte
mais vous venez de l'aborder quelle est
votre vision des grands enjeux
écologiques du monde ment et gabriela
talent sachant que vous avez décidé avec
votre ministre bien d'ouvrir le débat
dans les établissements scolaires
vendredi ils se disent c'est pas une
méthode un peu à l'algérienne pour
éviter les débordements on va essayer à
l'organiser c'est dans le cadre des
établissements c'est de donner la
possibilité à tous les jeunes qui le
souhaitent de pouvoir s'exprimer faire
des propositions c'est aussi faire
confiance à la jeunesse comme porteuse
de solutions comme porteuse de
propositions pour construire
effectivement pour construire un nouveau
modèle à la fois au niveau de leur
établissement comment on fait pour être
récupéré cet élan de la jeunesse
aujourd'hui pour le climat mais pas du
tout vous savez moi je moi je me réjouis
lui que la jeunesse française je suis
fier que la jeunesse française se
mobilise pour le climat dans ce moment
qui est un mouvement mondial
il y aura des mobilisations dans toutes
les grandes capitales européennes et
mondiales dans tous les
dans tout l'est dans tous les grands
pays pour envoyer un message parce que
la question du climat est je pense que
la question qui est posée par un
internaute
il fait référence elle n'est pas
uniquement franco française on voit bien
qu'il ya un enjeu européen parce que si
on veut être efficace il faut emmener
nos partenaires européens et on voit
bien que c'est un enjeu mondial à un
moment où un certain nombre de pays je
pense au brésil je pense aux états unis
font des choix qui sont désastreux pour
l'environnement et donc moi je suis fier
que la jeunesse française envoie un
message pour dire on n'est pas d'accord
avec ça on a envie de construire
l'avenir sur un autre modèle qui
préserve qui préserve l'environnement et
vous gérez vous la marche pour le climat
par exemple vendredi
oui je leur ai envie
j'avais envie d'y aller parce que je
très mobilisés sur ces questions là si
j'étais pas mieux me posera pas la
question parce que c'est un mouvement de
jeunesse je suis encore à peu près le
même du gouvernement
c'est ça le plus jeune mais mais oui
j'en ai j'en ai sans doute d'accord
alors dadis national toschi avant de
poser combien natale du no2 des
questions que j'ai préparé pour lui moi
je voudrais réagir deux secondes sur
bouteflika
parce que en tant que membre du
gouvernement vous pouviez rien dire et
vous n'avez rien dit moi je veux non je
me réjouis de ce qui se passe je pense
que c'est une bonne chose que bouteflika
ne se présente pas je vous dis
clairement serait été le mandat de trop
en plus les manifestations massives que
les religions se sont passées dans le
calme elles ont été efficaces la preuve
je reviens j'ai la réponse fuyante de
notre invité mais il pouvait pas faire
autrement il pouvait passer des dix
membres du gouvernement nommés juges
je n'en veux pas il peut pas un problème
de bois là dessus tu peux pas faire
autrement mais simplement pour dire ce
qui se passe en algérie est très
important pour nous c'est un pays voisin
un pays ami les liens sont
extraordinaires et donc on regarde avec
attention le fait que tout soit
repoussée est une bonne chose
maintenant dans l'étape suivante quelles
vont être les mêmes temps et nous sommes
très vigilants leur ministre français ne
peut pas le dire mais je trouve qu'il
peut le dire comme je suis pas ministre
je veux dire que je partage pas cet avis
je pense que l'algérie nous a quand même
montré une preuve de maturité et ont
trouvé une solution qu'une solution
digne pour tout le monde alors monsieur
peut être ce qui vous gardez la parole
parce que vous avez préparé des
questions à la vente il a choisi débat
un petit mot sur des pages je suis venu
vous parler des questions notamment du
sc nul de service national du vers celle
dont vous êtes responsables et pour
lequel vous n'avez pas répondu que vous
êtes venu au sénat mardi dernier bien
avant sur les débats en question le
débat le le gouvernement voulurent
enfermer le débat d'un capitaine j'étais
ravie comme de vous entendre dire que ça
allait pouvoir déborder de ce que ce qui
s'est passé sur le terrain notamment
tout ce qui s'est passé dans nos mairies
beaucoup de citoyens sont venus et ont
gratté comme débat
ils ont écrit ils ont déposé des mois
c'est sympathique avec une multitude de
fautes d'orthographe
mais ça allait dans tous les cerveaux de
questions non mais ma question et
surtout est-ce que vous allez accepter
que ça déborde totalement alors il est
très important parce que vous allez de
se voir tout le monde vous allez de se
voir ceux qui sont venus au débat vous
allez de recevoir des gilets jaunes qui
se considère un peu comme exclus du
débat est donc le mécontentement risque
d'être partout ce qui était important
c'était de fixer un cadre pour le débat
s'il y avait eu aucun cadre on nous
aurait expliqué que finalement c'était
totalement débordant qu'on n'allait pas
comment est-ce qu'on allait pouvoir
prendre en compte ce qui a été dit si ça
partait dans tous les sens donc c'était
important qu'ils aient un cadre mais on
a mis en place une méthode qui permet
d'identifier des sujets qui ont été
abordés et qui ne rentrent pas dans les
quatre grandes thématiques et j'ai cité
tout à l'heure je suis j'ai notamment en
asie vous et l'éducation
bien évidemment ces derniers rentrent
depuis deux ans en tout cas en ce qui
concerne l'éducation qui est le sujet
aujourd'hui sur lequel je travaille avec
jean michel blanquer évidemment que ça
sera pris en compte c'est un travail
extrêmement dense qui est fait
aujourd'hui qui est inédit vous l'avais
dit il ya beaucoup de municipalités qui
se sont engagés qui ont mis en place des
cahiers de contribution citoyenne 16000
alors baptisé merlin
vous savez que les maires se sont sentis
agressés par le comportement de en
marche depuis deux ans ils ont joué le
jeu de manière incroyable il était déçu
par vous par en marge des super macro et
ils ont ouvert leurs portes donnent leur
mairie ils se trouvèrent leur cahier et
ils ont joué notamment le jeu donc
respecté l'est eux aussi en acceptant de
lire tout ce qui était proposé
d'examiner les propositions et on les
respecte et je les respecte je fais
partie on est quelques députés haut
responsable la république en marche à
être par ailleurs élus locaux je pensais
plutôt pour département ont été bien
accueillis sa venue a été apprécié je
vais refaire démocratie je suis content
et je conseiller municipal dans ma
commune depuis 2014 donc ce sera parce
que font les élus locaux il a été élu
assuré liste de rassemblement de
centre-gauche
mais effectivement j'étais socialiste à
l'époque mais je suis élu local depuis
2014 et je sais le travail remarquable
que font les élus en l'occurrence non
plus je suis élu dans une zone urbaine
en petite couronne parisienne
dans la ruralité j'ai vu dans un certain
nombre de déplacements il ya un
dévouement un travail remarquable des
madame george pau-langevin appartenance
sociale seulement donc là vous avez
évoqué le fait que les jeunes sont très
intéressés par les questions les enjeux
écologiques et nous bien évidemment nous
pensons que quelque chose qui est très
important pour l'avenir de tout le monde
mais est ce que vous ne pensez pas quand
même que le bilan à ce jour est un peu
mais ce sur ces sujets là nous avons vu
ce qu'a dit nicolas hulot est par
ailleurs quand nous regardons l'intérêt
que vous dites porté au sujet et que
nous voyons les déclarations du
président notamment au conseil européen
au devant les instances européennes
on se dit qu'il ya quand même un certain
décalage par ailleurs je voulais aussi
vous interroger sur parcours sup
comprenez maintenant moi décalage moi je
comprends que certains auraient souhaité
qu'on aille plus vite plus fort tout de
suite sur la question de l'environnement
et l'écologie et en même temps je me
demande si on peut trouver dans
l'histoire politique des dernières
années des dernières décennies une
majorité qui a fait autant aussi vite
pour la question faiblit pas avec
l'écologie comme bartoli non je suis pas
daccord aux fruits mais je suis bien
placé pour le savoir eh oui mais la cap
21 d'ailleurs c'était pas au début du
quinquennat je dis aussi vite en aussi
peu de temps au bout de deux ans je sais
pas si le précédent quinquennat au bout
de deux ans pouvait revendiquer le même
bilan en matière d'environnement
je n'en suis pas sûr bahia je suis et
plusieurs lois je suis pas sûr qu'elle
faisait bousculer les choses nous qu'est
ce qu'on a fait on a voté une loi qui
interdit la recherche et l'exploitation
d'hydrocarbures en france on est le
premier pays à le faire
on est en train de présenter d'ailleurs
c'est pour le rendre encore plus
efficace
on va présenter une loi sur l'énergie
qui va faire en sorte qu'on ferme les
centrales a géré bombay dans la
continuité de ce qui avait été fait
précédemment
oui enfin je veux dire françois hollande
a été lu en annonçant qu'il fermera
fessenheim fessenheim est encore
aujourd'hui en marche ce qui en ferait
bien voilà mais est ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est bien de prendre des
pauses engagement est de dire qu'on va
faire des choses
après il faut les mettre contrat
concrètement en oeuvre il faut donner de
la prévisibilité et ce qu'on est ce
qu'on est en train de faire on a
présenté un plan sur la biodiversité
avec un agenda extrêmement clairs un
calendrier sur la fin du plastique on va
présenter une loi sur l'économie
circulaire on a arraché au niveau
européen la limitation du glyphosate du
renouvellement alors ses enfants c'est
un sujet contesté donc pas sa photo fait
beaucoup interpellé à ce sujet mais ce
qui est ce qui a été contesté c'est
est-ce que vous portiez avec votre
groupe c'est qu'on inscrive pas dans la
loi c'est un choix qui a été fait
politique ce qui est incontestable c'est
qu'un certain nombre d'états pousser
pour un renouvellement de 15 ans du
glyphosate et que parce que le président
macro et à l'époque nicolas hulot il
faut le dire se sont mobilisés on a
obtenu un renouvellement de cinq ans en
europe
on aurait souhaité que ça soit moi
d'ailleurs non va faire moins mais on a
obtenu sa part - ne laissez pas les
agriculteurs français mais c'est
justement pour ça comptera suspects la
règle européenne souhaitait que le plus
de transparence et que justement si on
va un peu plus vite pour en france eh
bien il faudrait que le consommateur
sache si le produit qu'il achète a été
fait en france sans glyphosate ou a été
fait en italie ou en allemagne avec des
chaussettes et ça vous n'avez pas voulu
ce qui est certain c'est ce sur quoi on
s'est engagés c'est que je lis pas dans
trois ans puisque c'était ce qu'on donc
là c'est dans un an et demi on sera
sorti du glyphosate c'est un engagement
qui est très fort et encore une fois il
faut le souligner et on travaille que
les agriculteurs oui j'étais au stand de
l'inra au salon de l'agriculture
il ya un travail exceptionnel qui est
fait par des chercheurs pour trouver des
alternatives parce que effectivement
c'est facile de décréter la bataille des
écologistes voire mais par ailleurs
parcours super ça fait que c'est quand
même quelque chose qui vraiment pris
beaucoup les jeunes de ce devoir choisir
leurs universités avec des risques de
retard ou de refus considérable l'an
dernier l'été a été une sorte d'épreuve
permanente où il regardé tous les jours
leur dossier progressé sur parcours sup
donc vous avez corriger un certain
nombre de choses mais est ce qu'il n'ya
pas une contradiction a organisé
l'entrée dans le supérieur
avant de réformer le bac parce que je
sais quoi mais en sachant que vous étiez
le rapporteur de ce texte comme
absolument réputé on a beaucoup
travaillé débattu madame prolongement
s'est même accordé sur certains points
puisqu'il ya des amendements qui ont été
adoptées qui étaient portées par l'envol
en vous intéressant c'est sur les
risques de couacs à nouveau en 7 mai
c'est quand même de relisez vous
permettrait quand même de rappeler en
termes de quoique ce qui existait avant
parcours sup avant parcours su que
c'était des jeunes qui attendaient
pendant l'essai s'était déjà inquiété et
là on a adapté le calendrier
effectivement pour que ça aille plus
vite en faisant que les délais pour
répondre soit un peu plus réduit en
faisant qui en créant ce qu'on appelle
un répondeur automatique pour que si des
jeunes sont sûrs de leur choix
c'est dans la machine et les veut donc
se demander finalement non ça prouve
qu'il faut c'est une préférence un coup
de coeur à tous cas et ça c'est ça c'est
important moi je veux quand même redire
que parcours sup c'est un progrès
exceptionnels pour les jeunes on a + 30
% de jeunes boursiers qui accède au
supérieur + 30 % de boursiers en classes
prépa et là dessus on peut saluer le
travail qu'on a fait en commun puisque
c'est grâce à un amendement que vous
aviez portée auxquels j'ai donné un avis
favorable comme quoi on voit quoi sur
des sujets on peut s'accorder
on a + 30 % de jeunes boursiers sur
critères sociaux qui rentrent en
préparant cpg on a eu des relations qui
sont faites assez à ce texte
finalement on reprend un peu des choses
ce que nous avions proposé et qui ont
été qui réutilise refusé à l'époque
d'abord aller on en parle maintenant de
du grand sujet la grande réforme que
vous allez porter effectivement la 17e
match ce qui le service national
universel dont vous êtes responsable
vous êtes venu devant le sénat mardi
dernier et vous n'avez pratiquement
répondu à aucune des questions de fond
qui va vous a posé et notamment la plus
importante
comment allez vous payer ça ce que vous
n'êtes arrivez-vous bosque en novembre
2018 certains avaient travaillé avant
général mais darwin a fait un travail
vraiment approfondi lui a donné des
chiffres
il a dit que ça coûterait plus de 3
milliards 3 milliards 3 alors je vous
apprends votre heure le son un milliard
sept d'investissement et un milliard 6
par an en année pleine quand on va
prendre vous allez prendre en charge les
huit cent mille jeunes chaque génération
donc 3 milliards 3 points dont vous avez
inscrit 0
même la phase expérimentale qui va
commencer en juin prochain rien n'a été
inscrit pas plus à l'assemblée qu'au
sénat sur cette phase expérimentale
elle coûtera peut-être pas très cher
j'ai regardé d'à peu près puisque leur
sera des départements cobayes
je crois que vous trouverez en hiver je
ne suis allé
trouvez les volontaires je vais vous
dire pourquoi pas ce que vous leur ferez
deux choses quinze jours je vais dire un
petit peu de vacances ils vont aller
dans un autre département par des
centres de loisirs
c'est la cohésion mais quand on veut
leur apprendre un certain nombre de
choses pour le brésil en santé quand
même on va apprendre les noms mais non
c'est bien ce qui est bien mais c'est
bien voient leur apprends voir où est
leur niveau de français leur niveau
numérique tout ça est très très bien
brassage social en quinze jours non
alors les gens discours mais réponse
normale le coup à leurs réponses en
aller mais pas l'expérience à un des
plaids 3 milliards 3 réponses mais il
vous croyez pas qu'il ya mieux à faire
que dépenser 30 milliards 3 pour ça sur
les retraites pour les allocations
familiales pour plein d'autres choses
que nous avons trois que vous n'avez pas
je vais vous répondre en deux temps
d'abord je suis très heureux de vous
entendre dire que ça va être un moment
utile c'est pas quinze jours ces deux
fois quinze jours il ya les quinze jours
de connivence et du tout dans une autre
région et quinze jours de mission
d'intérêt général et redire ça va être
très utile pour vous avez déjà personnes
ça va être une association ça va être la
plus du mairie de ce que vous êtes sûr
tout ceci ne s'apprend mais moi je vous
êtes dessus plus je vous ai pas je
serais pour sur le budget je vous dis
enfin sur les missions d'intérêt général
on travaille avec des grands réseaux
associatifs ont signé des conventions
avec eux je vais signer une convention
avec la fève
je ne travaille que la ligue de
l'enseignement travail unis cité avec
des grands réseaux associatifs avec la
croix rouge qui vous permettent de
mettre en place des missions et sur les
municipalités
j'ai bien dit que y avait aucune
obligation ce que je constate c'est
qu'il ya énormément de mairie qui sont
favorables et qui sont volontaires pour
proposer de l'argent sur l'argent leur
importance mais mais sur l'argent j'ai
enfin on fait on met en place une phase
pilote
vous l'avez dit en juin prochain dans 13
départements dont l'heure qu'un
magnifique département qui est une très
belle base aérienne à evreux qui va
servir pour le verset national universel
une phase pilote qui vise d'abord à
tester nos organisations à voir qu'il ya
des choses à ajuster à tester le taux
d'encadrement on a retenu qui est un
taux d'encadrement qui est extrêmement
élevé un encadrant pour cinq jeunes
quand vous connaissez un peu l'accueil
collectif de mineurs normalement c'est
un poudre oui mais ça un coup sûr un
pour cinq mais est-ce qu'on va rester
sur un pour cinq par exemple je vous
donne qu'un exemple à l'issue de la
phase pilote
on va prendre des décisions qui auront
un impact sur le coût du dispositif en
année pleine est donc ce que j'ai dit au
sénat
est-ce que je redis ici
c'est que vous trouverez les curieux
aujourd'hui j'annonce un budget en
rythme de croisière alors même que je
dis on va prendre des décisions à
l'issue de la phase pilote
ce que je peux vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est que pour la phase pilote est ce
que j'ai dit au sénat en transparence on
a aujourd'hui un budget de 4 millions
d'euros que si on extrapole ça fait
environ un milliard cinq sur une année à
rythme de croisière mais que ça ne peut
être que indicatif puisque par
définition on va prendre des décisions à
l'étude de la phase pilote qui auront un
impact sur le budget et moi je trouve
qu'il faut saluer aussi cette méthode on
est économe de nos moyens et
fragmentaire que j'approuve vous seriez
par un problème mental
franchement si on se lançait dans un
projet comme ça concerne huit cent mille
jeunes d'un coup sans avoir testé notre
organisation et sans avoir mesuré ce
qu'on était capable de faire
on nous dirait attendait là vous vous
lancez quand même parce qu'ils soient
qu'ils taxent voilà césar sur qui le
remet à y aura un vrai camp militaire
c'est ce qu'on appelle le retour
d'expérience figurez-vous qui aura un
beau tenir compte du retour d'expérience
le mois de juillet et éventuellement
abandonner certaines choses et de faire
d'autres différemment lors des audiences
sur le sol intex entre juillet et
octobre prochain justement pour tenir
compte des enseignements c'est que si
vous aviez quelque chose qui
fonctionnait bien qu était le service
civique et on se demande pourquoi on
n'avait pas simplement développer le
service civique qui d'ailleurs
fonctionne sur une base de volontariat
plutôt que de se bousculer à nouveau
l'organisation pour les jeunes qui
s'achète pas à pas s'en tenir et c'est
justement tu dire tout à fait la beauté
obligatoire de côté obligatoire va quand
même posé problème assez d'accord avec
vous quand vous dites que le service
civique est un outil formidable et qu'il
faut le renforcer
laurent force et ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire oui mettre des moyens
supplémentaires et le rendre bien mais
50 millions d'euros en plus 50 millions
en plus sur 2019 c'était votée dans le
budget dans le contexte c'est quand même
pas mal pour le service civique le
deuxième moyen de le renforcer c'est
quoi c'est de faire en sorte que plus de
jeunes qui a envie d'aller faire un
service civique et moi je croise
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont en service
civique qui se retrouver là un peu par
la force des choses nous sauver il était
poli décrocheurs qui se retrouvaient en
service civique parce que m sur lequel
on leur a dit va faire un service
civique et pour qui ça a été une
révélation
ils me disent c'est la première fois
qu'on m'a dit merci c'est la première
fois que me suis senti utile et pourquoi
est donc logique de volonté mais bien
sûr on peut aimer encore mais pour que
ce soir lequel dieu c'est pour que ça
soit parce que ce n'est pas le même
parce que c'est aller bien et si on veut
qu'ils aient plus de jeunes qu'ils
soient volontaires pour faire le service
civique
encore faut-il qu'ils aient plus de
jeunes qui se disent qu'ils ont le choix
et qu'ils ont quelque chose à apporter
vous avez un drame dans notre pays
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a énormément de
mal à montrer à toute notre jeunesse son
utilité sociale
vous avez des bataillons entiers de
jeunes qui se disent qu'ils n'ont rien à
rapporter
donc forcément ils vont pas candidaté
sur un service il ils se disent qu'ils
n'ont rien à apporter à la société est
l'objectif du service national avec la
mission d'intérêt général c'est qu'ils
puissent mesurer ce sentiment qu'ils
puissent voir
oui je peux être utile auprès d'une
association auprès d'une collectivité
auprès d'un corps en uniforme et
derrière puisque ça fait partie du
service national choisir de s'engager
volontairement dans le service civique
je rappelle qu'il ya deux phases au
service national la phase obligatoire
d'un mois une phase volontaires qui
s'appuie sur des engagements volontaires
le service civique les pompiers
volontaires la réserve opérationnelle du
bénévolat dans une association
c'est ces deux et moi je ne sais pas
regagné 2 avec le côté obligatoire on
peut craindre qu on se retrouve comme à
la fin du service militaire ou c'est
peut-être vrai sport pour les familles
de faire exonéré leurs peurs leurs
enfants aille alors il y aurait des
ambitions projet de réforme heures il
n'y aura pas d'exemption et par aucune
novak a vu est-ce que c'est universel et
qu'on veut que tous les jeunes en leur
disant 'on est même pas répondre aux
convocations savez moi je me déplace
énormément dans les collèges dans les
lycées et je discute avec beaucoup de
jeunes
on va peut être des déserteurs ce que je
rencontre c'est qu'un intérêt très fort
pour le dispositif vous savez le service
national on la construit notamment grâce
au rapport du général mais darwin mais
grâce à une consultation numérique il ya
cinquante mille jeunes représentatifs de
la diversité de la jeunesse qui ont
contribué et qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit
ils ont dit un nouveau des formations à
une société où les risques ont évolué et
comment on réagit face à une catastrophe
naturelle
on est en place un poste de secours on
vient en secours aux sinistrés comment
ont réagi face à un attentat terroriste
comment on maîtrise les gestes de
premiers secours tout ça on va leur
apprendre et l'autre enjeu est bien sûr
en quinze jours mais vous savez on peut
faire beaucoup de choses avec les
pompiers volontaires avec la croix rouge
ils ont construit des mots dieu lui
c'est fait pour leur apprendre tout ça
c'est celui-là voilà il faut avoir
inscrit alizés on verra en france le
président veut que 80% de la population
soit formé a réagi on verra comment ils
vendent leur projet puisque
effectivement il ya une phase
expérimentale qui commence au moins deux
autres et figuration préfiguration que
si l'on merci à tous les deux c'est à 3
parti désormais d'audition jugé qu'avec
nos deux concerts qui font leur entrée
sur le plateau
[Musique]
en parler des universités bonsoir
brigitte busch et ryan mancini merci
d'être là une question d'un internaute
du figaro on parlait des universités
alors là un point de vue un peu un peu
contraire à celui des organisations
syndicales d'étudiants puisque sept
internautes du figaro nous dit alors que
les étudiants français ont du mal à
boucler leurs fins de mois pourquoi
financer les frais et les études
d'étudiants étrangers quelle est votre
position dans ce débat du moment
écoutez série b renchérissement bien sûr
les frais d'inscription pour les
étudiants étrangers
c'est une décision qui a été prise qui
est porté par un frédéric vidal qui vise
à dire que aujourd'hui on a un système
où les inscriptions à l'université est
quasi gratuite quasiment pour tous les
étudiants qui viennent de france ou de
pays étrangers
or on a des pays étrangers où les jeunes
étudiants qui vont s'inscrire paye
plusieurs milliers parfois plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros pour
réaliser leur étude et que donc on met
en place un tarif pour des étudiants
étrangers qui viennent en france avec
pour s'assurer de l'égal accès un
triplement des bourses parce qu'il ya
des étudiants étrangers qui ne peuvent
pas se payer forcément plusieurs
rubriques d'euros et moi je veux dire
que les étudiants étrangers c'est une
chance pour la france
un étudiant étranger qui vient étudier
en france d'abord il aborde il apporte
des choses aux autres étudiants ensuite
quand il repart dans son pays
c'est un petit l'ambassadeur de france à
son niveau qui fait vivre les valeurs de
la france qui fait rayonner la france
on a besoin d'étudiants étrangers on a
besoin de les accueillir dans de bonnes
conditions et c'est ce que porte
frédéric vidal avec ce projet pour faire
en sorte que des jeunes étrangers qui ne
peuvent pas se payer entre guillemets
les nouveaux droits d'inscription
puisque voilà les yeux sur les bosses
mais ils sont pas tous bourse et non
elle sera pas globalement mais il y en a
d'autres qui peuvent assumer ce tarif
puisque d'ailleurs quand ils vont dans
d'autres pays il assume pour entrer à
l'université
d'accord pour rien mais il y en a
d'autres que vous en avez parlé m'ont à
d'autres questions sur le service
national universel vous avez ouvert il
ya une semaine le 4 mars
la plate forme d'inscription en ligne
pour les recruter des volontaires
combien vous avez description à ce jour
alors j'ai un point hebdomadaire
et pour tout vous dire j'aurai la
réponse alors j'aurai peut-être plus à
demander pour venir sur le plateau
dans la soirée ce qui est ce que je sais
c'est qu'on a eu plusieurs milliers de
connexions déjà la semaine dernière sur
la plateforme qui permet d'accéder à
chacun d'accéder dans chacun des
départements à l'adresse pour pour
s'inscrire donc je cale objectif vous
est fixé l'objectif c'est d'avoir entre
2000 et 3000 jeunes au niveau au niveau
national ça c'est le premier objectif en
terme de non moi je double cet objectif
je les dis d'un objectif de diversité
des jeunes de cap non mais ça c'est un
point important c'est que si on met en
place un dispositif sur la base du
volontariat et qu'on dise ce qu'ils ont
l'info bas inscrivez vous on a n'est pas
certain d'avoir une diversité de jeune à
la fin et moi ce que je veux c'est qu'on
aille chercher des volontaires y compris
certains qui n'auraient pas se seraient
pas portés candidats spontanément
autrement dit on a absolument pas de
problème à voir des volontaires d'une
manière générale mais moi je veux des
volontaires de tous types
je vois des jeunes qui sont au lycée je
veux des jeunes qui sont décrocheurs
jouer des jeunes qui sont en
apprentissage assuré c'est à travers ce
site et sur les apprentis on travaille
avec les cfa sur les décrocheurs entre
avec les missions locales sur les jeunes
en situation de handicap
on travaille avec les mdph maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
pour aller chercher des volontaires le
service national universel est pas loin
quand même très loin de la promesse de
départ d' emmanuel macron c'était qu'ils
soient encadrés par l'armée par la
gendarmerie et qu'il dure entre trois et
six mois est-ce que c'est pas un temps
nécessaire aussi pour former une classe
d'âge pour réunir et qui est cette
mixité sociale et réunir sur des valeurs
républicaines est ce qu'on n'est pas
très très loin finalement de cette
prouesse de départ une seule différence
par rapport à l'engagement qui avait été
annoncé pendant la campagne par le
président de la république que candidat
d'alors c'est l'âge
sinon c'était un service national
universel d'un mois après il ya eu des
questions qui se sont posées
dans les mois qui ont suivi son élection
sur la durée ce qu'on faisait plus est
ce qu'on vous et moi mais dans le
programme de campagne à mon corps est à
moi un mois encadrés par des militaires
le service national universel qu'on
propose durera un mois très encadrés par
des militaires
la seule différence c'est qu'il était
prévu à 18 ans et que on a fait le choix
de l'avancé à 16 ans pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce qu'à 18 ans il ya
énormément de différences de statut chez
les jeunes et que ça peut venir percuter
un certain nombre de projets ensuite
parce que l'un des objectifs c'est aussi
de faire en sorte de prévenir le
décrochage de faire en sorte qu'ils
aient moins de jeunes qui décrochent
il ya cent mille jeunes chaque année qui
quittent le système scolaire sans
diplôme sans qualification qui se
retrouvent sans emploi est donc
l'objectif à 16 ans c'est peut-être de
travailler avec eux pour éviter qu'ils
décrochent et de leur construire un
parcours de formation adaptés et vous
pouvez nous assurer qu'il sera
généralisé et avant la fin du
quinquennat
alors généralisation est prévue à ce
stade par le rapport du général mais
darwin en 2026 moi ce que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire c'est que je
souhaitais qu'on regarde dans quelle
mesure on peut aller un peu plus vite
évidemment c'est tout le travail qu'on
est en train de faire là et la phase
pilote qui nous diront dans quelle
mesure on peut aller on peut aller plus
vite et plus loin c'est quoi 2022 2023
oui c'est ça ou 2024 1025ce tout ça sert
en 2000 d'accidents non mais la date ci
voulait pas partir des serments avant at
on l'attendait quinquennat on rentre on
met en place une phase pilote justement
pour tester notre organisation tester
nos choix pratique c'est aussi de ça que
vient un moment cédé coup l'ailier de
2022 2023
c'est oui parce qu'on est petit c'est
comme vous êtes en train de le faire
dans mes retranchements pour que je
donne une date mais ce que je dis c'est
que aujourd'hui c'est prévu en 2026 par
le rapport du général ménard wind que je
souhaite qu'on aille plus vite si c'est
possible et plus vite fait de le
renverser le 23 l'idée c'est de le
généraliser et qui se rendent à thouars
pour toute possibilité de retour en
arrière
je ne crois pas une seconde que certains
voudront retourner un accord parce que
franchement je pense que ça va avoir un
impact considérable pour notre jeunesse
est d'ailleurs un impact qui fait écho à
beaucoup de choses qu'on voit
aujourd'hui que nous la santé oms
d'appartenance nationale par sur
sentiment d'appartenance sur les
fractures qu'on voit rien les gilet
jaune c'est quand même des personnes qui
sont sorties sur les ronds-points qui
ont dit on à l'impression d'habiter
dans le même pays que d'autres mais ne
pas vivre la même chose que les autres
et c'est vrai qu'on a un drame en france
c'est qu'on a des populations et
notamment des jeunesse qui se parlent
peu qu'ils se rencontrent peu qui
évoluent dans un couloir qui ont
l'impression que le champ de leurs
possibles se limite à ce couloir
c'est vrai que la journée il aura le
temps de se parler fois quinze jours et
oui vous savez on compare souvent pour
dormir de son temps on compare souvent
avec le service militaire qui duraient
plusieurs mois etc
les classes c'était un mois et c'était
quand même le plus bas le brassage durée
quand même besoin via les plus trop de
drapeaux le drapeau dans les classes ça
participe de la même démarche
c'est un amendement qui a été adopté
dans le cadre de la loi de jean michel
blanquer hier par les députés
vous en pensez quoi moi je pense que la
droite un départ et je pense que ça
ça fait pas de mal voilà si vous laissez
ces jeux font pas l'avenir de l'école
sur ce sujet là mais je vois pas ce que
ça retire ou ce que ça fait de mal
l'observatoire de la laïcité qui avait
préconisé d'autoriser les jeunes qui
participent aux essais mieux à porter
des signes religieux voile islamique qui
pas est ce que cela pourra être le cas
ou pas non j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
la neutralité religieuse sera respectée
dans le service national universel comme
elle l'est aujourd'hui dans le cadre
scolaire comme elle l'est aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de la j -dc la journée
défense et citoyenneté comme elle
l'était à l'époque du service militaire
que des hommes donc il y avait peut-être
certains points qui se posaient mois
mais évidemment la neutralité religieuse
sur une forme y aura une tenue commune
alors l'uniforme
oui ce qui sera pas un gros mot sera
proposée aux jeunes et moi j'ai souhaité
qu'elles soient dessinés par les jeunes
j'ai lancé un concours dans 13 lycées
professionnels dans des filières mode et
design ils sont en train de plancher
sadr avait beaucoup j'ai quelques échos
et à la fin de la semaine prochaine
je réunirai un jury de quatre personnes
oui qui vont à choisir d'accord tenu des
jeunes très bien aussi à suivre donc
oriane oui sur le un autre dossier après
le braquage d'un produit bien d'une
professeur par un élève en octobre
dernier jean michel blanquer christophe
castaner avait promis un plan ambitieux
pour lutter contre les violences à
l'école on en doute ce plan alors
d'abord il ya une première série de
mesures qui ont déjà été annoncés par
jean michel blanquer
à la fin de l'année dernière je charley
rappeler parce qu'elles sont importantes
notamment la mise en place au sein de
l'éducation nationale au sein des
établissements d'un système qui fait que
tout acte signalé par un professeur et
un suivi et une réponse le drame et le
fameux pas de vagues qui avait été mis
en avant par les professeurs c'est que
certains avaient l'impression parfois de
hurler dans le vide et de dire voilà je
me suis fait agresser il ya un élément
perturbateur dans ma classe qui me met
en difficulté il n'ya pas de suivi des
personnes âgées on a mis en place un
système qui fait qu' il ya un sujet
maintenant pour tout acte signaler qu'il
ya une réaction que si un enseignant a
l'impression dans son établissement
y a pas de réaction ou peut saisir via
une adresse mail
un interlocuteur qui vient et ça c'est
pour les réponses éducation nationale
ensuite il ya des questions qui se
posent qui sont interministériel comment
est-ce qu'on responsabilise mieux les
familles et les élèves parce qu'il ya
aussi un enjeu est le ministère de
l'intérieur
comment est ce que on gère des jeunes
qui seraient poli exclu d'arthur a été
exclu plusieurs fois je serai vraiment
des éléments hautement perturbateurs
comme on dit dans quelle structure est
ce qu'on peut les accueillir ça fait
beaucoup de questions que vous avez du
mal à les tranchées apparemment bien
travail là on l'attend oui un travail qu
est ce que vous êtes pour la sanction
financière de certaines familles n'ont
plus d'enfants seront pas tenues moi je
pense qu'il faut responsabiliser un
certain nombre de familles je pense
qu'il faut faire du cas par cas
je peux donner des exemples vous êtes
une mère de famille seule une mère
célibataire vous avez quatre enfants ou
cinq enfants
vous en avez un ne vous n'arrivez pas à
gérer vous êtes dépassés par les
événements bah on va peut-être pas vous
faire payer une amende parce que vous
êtes dans cette situation si vous êtes
des parents qui assumait totalement le
fait que votre enfant soit difficile à
l'école agressé son professeur et
d'ailleurs vous vous rendez à l'école et
que vous prenez partie de votre enfant
face au professeur l'a peut-être qu'il
peut y avoir une responsabilisation en
tout cas moi je pense qu'il doit y en
avoir d'accord donc aux allocations
familiales par exemple le plan il sera
présenté dans les prochaines semaines ça
prend un temps de retard en fait parce
que c'est un gros travail
interministériel parce que ça associe la
justice l'intérieur l'éducation
nationale parce qu'à des dimensions qui
sont quand même non
non non neutre donc mais c'est imminent
sur parcours sup
l'unef a mené une enquête auprès des
élèves qui n'avaient aucune proposition
pour parcours sup en 2018 le syndicat
étudiant note une surreprésentation des
bacs pros et des bacs technologiques et
certains dénoncent des discriminations
avec votre réforme parce que la
sélection à l'université pas devenue une
réalité finalement non enfin on regarde
évidemment ces situations là avec
beaucoup d'attention il ya un énorme
travail qui a été fait pour accompagner
les jeunes qui n'avaient pas de réponse
jusqu'où ça date pas d'aujourd'hui qui
est des jeunes qui étaient candidats en
bts ou en iut
c'est souvent le cas des bacs pros et
des bacs techno qui sont des filières
sélectives là dessus rien n'a changé que
par coups reçus et qui n'ont pas eu de
réponse ça date pas d'aujourd'hui on a
toujours eu ce que je constate c'est que
cette année grâce à la réforme par coups
reçus et grâce aux ouvertures de classes
qu'on a fait et grâce au placement et
aux planchers en bts et en iut
il ya 30% de bac pro en plus qui ont
accédé à un bts 30% de bac techno en
plus qui ont accédé à un qui ont accédé
à l'imiter et ça c'était très important
il ya sans doute des jeunes qui sont
beaucoup moins nombreux qu'à l'époque
d'apb qui se retrouvait sans solution et
il faut les accompagner il faut faire en
sorte de trouver une solution est de
construire une surtaxe de représentation
justement bac pro et techno parce que ce
que je dis c'est que malheureusement
c'était déjà le cas avant mais surtout
c'est beaucoup moins le cas puisqu'il ya
beaucoup plus de bacs techno et de bac
pro qui ont accédé à l'enseignement
supérieur ça augmenté de 30%
c'est évidemment pas suffisant il faut
continuer le travail avec eux c'est ce
qu'on fait et forêts supplémentaires ont
des places supplémentaires à
l'université à la rentrée prochaine
on analyse au cas par cas on va aussi
analyser les voeux qui sont faits par
les jeunes et en fonction des venant
c'est que chacun beaucoup d'étudiants
j'y arrive je l'aimé pas et pas
suffisamment de passe mais les
accueillir et vous savez l'an dernier il
y avait une centaine de milliers de
places qui étaient restés vacances à
l'issue de la campagne d'apb alors qu'à
des jeunes qui se sont retrouvés sans
place c'est que la difficulté c'est
moins le nombre de places que
l'adéquation entre la demande et l'offre
et donc les demandes et les voeux qui
vont être formulée par les états les
lycéens en terminale vont nous permettre
d'adapter cet autre chose maintenant au
rayonnement de genève sur la pma puisque
le calendrier ne sombre ne semble pas
très clair l'examen déjà été repoussées
marlène ce cap a dit que le texte sera
examiné avant l'été c'est ce qu'a
également dit aujourd'hui benjamin
griveaux marc fesneau lui parle plutôt
d'un calendrier d'ici à la fin de
l'année est ce que le gouvernement et la
majorité ont encore besoin de temps ils
ne sont pas prêts sur cette question moi
je ne crois pas
le texte sera présenté avant l'été ça a
été annoncé par le porte parole du
gouvernement il sera examiné dès que
possible dans un calendrier législatif
qui est quand même très contraint je
pense que c'est avant tout le sujet moi
je pense que l'un des divisions au sein
de la majorité sur le sujet je crois moi
je vais t'en sors pas tant que ça bon je
vois tant que ça à quelques individus
qui ont fait part de leur opposition et
le débat s'exprime c'est normal sur la
pma il me semble qu'il ya quand même un
consensus assez large dans la dans la
majorité
moi ce qui m'importe ce à quoi j'appelle
c'est que nous juge sur cette question
là pour ceux qui sont mobilisés sur
cette question là à la fin du
quinquennat
à la fin du quinquennat on verra si on a
trouvé ça vachement sympa oui mais vous
allez pourquoi je parle je dis ça parce
que le précédent quinquennat
vous avez un candidat françois hollande
qui s'était engagé à autoriser la pma
pour les couples de femmes et à la fin
du quinquennat ça n'avait jamais été
fait et donc peut-être que sur le
calendrier législatif c'est un peu c'est
un peu compliqué mais ça sera portée
dans l'est plus dans les délais les plus
rapides pour ce métier je le disais tout
à l'heure député la république en marché
encore quelques mois est ce que vous
auriez signé aujourd'hui la pétition de
certains élus qui dénoncent dans votre
parti l'homophobie et le sexisme vous
avez vu cela j'ai pas alors je n'ai pas
vu c'était il ya une pétition ils sont
13 je n'ai pas
tribune dans un magazine têtu sur le pmg
pas vu ça depuis très honnête serait pas
ce que j'ai fait a vu ça te met si la
question que vous avez déjà constaté des
faits de sexisme homophobie dans votre
partie non moi ce que enfin si la
question et je pense que ça doit être ça
c'est de savoir si certaines prises de
position individuelles ont heurté la
réponse est oui j'ai pas lu la médiation
des et j'ai pas eu la pétition portée
certains types de même que des positions
qu'elle a pu porter contre la pma m'ont
aussi heurté en tant qu enfant issu
d'une crème à gt mais leurs rituels
sanctionner ça n'a pas été le cas elle a
une simple mise en garde de la
république en marche
moi je suis enfin je suis pour qu'on
dise quand on n'est pas d'accord je suis
pour qu'on dénonce un certain nombre de
propos je suis pas pour qu'on sanctionne
à tout va sur la base d'opinions qui
sont portées soit une opinion qui est
portée va contre la loi et à ce moment
là il ya une procédure judiciaire il ya
une sanction par le parti mais il n'y a
pas de date pour moi les partis
politiques ont pas être des arbitres au
morro on peut tout à fait
isolé entre guillemets une parole sans
avoir à pratiquer la purge
visionnez municipales à paris a beaucoup
d'ambition à la république en marché ce
qui n'a pas trop d'ambition trop
d'ambition trop tôt moi ce qui est
certain c'est que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
l'important c'est d'être concentré sur
le grand débat national et ensuite sur
les élections européennes qui vont
intervenir prochainement et moi je
souhaite qu'on ait un vrai débat
européen projette notre projet d'un
souvenir mais il est trop tôt pour moi
je leur dis que je souhaite qu'on se
concentre sur ces sujets là je pense que
c'est important je pense que c'est
l'essentiel ou alors
donc les ministres candidats mounir mais
jobim agen malgré vos doivent mettre
leurs ambitions personnelles de côté
pour le moment à benjamin griveaux n'a
pas à déclaré de tri des déchets
opposition déclarée de candidature à ce
que je sache à ce stade moi je
souhaiterais qu'il soit candidat puisque
je le deviendrai oui moi je pense que
benjamin vous serez un excellent
candidat mais il n'a pas est-ce qu'il
faut quitter le gouvernement justement
pour faire campagne pour les européennes
maintenant comme mounir n'a joui lui
s'est déclarée par exemple ça c'est
vraiment on sait qu'ils sont encore leur
place dans moi j'ai pas moi à dire si un
collègue doit quitter le gouvernement ou
par un premier ministre un président de
la république qui arbitres ces questions
là donc j'ai pas de position à prendre
sur ce sujet est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre un remaniement fin mars si il
a beaucoup de ces clubs mais c'est
peut-être deux listes éventuel pour les
européennes était au gouvernement
aujourd'hui si justement venir ma jolie
devait aller où benjamin griveaux faire
campagne pour les européennes est ce que
vous pensez que le timing de la fin mars
pour un remaniement est possible là
encore moi je suis ni premier ministre
ni président de la république c'est
vraiment à eux qu'il appartient de
décider s'il doit y avoir un remaniement
ce qui est certain c'est que j'imagine
que si des personnes sont amenés à
quitter le gouvernement elles devront
être remplacés c'est tout ce que je peux
dire à ce stade puisque vous parlez du
grand débat et des européennes est ce
que le grand débat et le grand débat
permanent puis qui va se prolonger jusqu
aux européennes et bien ça ne va pas
écraser cette campagne européenne ça ne
pas écraser le débat de fond sur
l'europe
moi je crois pas
le grand débat s'arrête le 15 avril et
c'est vrai qu'on va mettre en place une
pratique du pouvoir qui fait que nora en
permanence cette capacité des citoyens à
participer mais je pense qu'on va avoir
un vrai débat européen en tout cas je
m'en réjouis et vous me posez
régulièrement la question de la tête de
liste si on avait aujourd'hui une tête
de liste le débat se fera sans doute sur
les personnes avant de se faire sur
notre projet et en l'occurrence moi
j'étais très heureux de voir que ces
dernières semaines on a beaucoup parlé
du cap qui était proposée par emmanuel
macron dans sa tribune et c'était
important que le débat il se fasse sur
le projet et que peut-être que si on
avait eu une tête de liste on serait
plus intéressé aux personnes nous on
veut proposer une ambition et un cap
avant les personnes évidemment turquie
parce que vous avez vu la réponse de
berlin aujourd'hui
enfin hier dans une tribune au zeit
la nouvelle responsable de la cv aux
critiques assez fortement les
propositions mises en avant par emmanuel
macron parce que cela vous inquiète sur
l'avenir de lax franco allemand non ça
m'inquiète pas d'abord parce que il ya
un certain nombre et beaucoup de
responsables politiques de pays
européens qui ont pris position qui ont
soutenu la tribune ensuite il ya un
dialogue et une discussion avec
l'allemagne vous savez il ya un certain
nombre de dossiers qu'on poussait et
donc sur lesquels on nous disait
l'allemagne n'est pas d'accord vous n'y
arriverez pas etc
et à la fin on a réussi à les convaincre
et à les porter avec elle sur la
question du budget de la zone euro au
départ on nous disait ça n'arrivera
jamais c'est impossible
on y est parvenu sur un sujet qui me
tient à coeur moi en tant que secrétaire
d'état à l'éducation
le doublement du budget d'erasmus
d'accord c'est un projet comporte et la
flore les hamacs sociales ou les
protections sociales pour la cdo il n'y
a pas que pas question d'aller vers ce
qu'on appelle une européanisation par
exemple donc là c'est une fin de non
recevoir
et il ya une critique par exemple du
parlement à strasbourg est ce que là
vous avez l'intention de faire acte de
résistance
je ne suis pas tête de liste je savais
pas la campagne des européennes il y
aura un programme qui va être fait et
surtout il y aura sans doute un dialogue
qui va s'engager
moi en tout cas je crois que les
élections européennes ça va être un vrai
moment de clarifications sur ces sujets
européens
on a besoin d'une clarification on a eu
une europe des fondateurs qui a initié
un magnifique projet qu'est l'union
européenne on a eu ensuite une europe
des gestionnaires qui ont géré sans
projet politique et la question c'est
est ce qu'on veut une europe avec un
projet politique pour mieux protéger
pour mieux accompagner pour mieux
défendre nos industries et nos emplois
et ça ça va être un beau débat dans les
mois qui viennent très bien merci
beaucoup à vous bien royal attal d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui merci mesdames
bonsoir à tous ça très vite
[Musique]